Continue from the last section or open the level named 04 Cinematics Render. If you need to, select and open the level sequence that is in this level.
Now that we have the animation sequence defined, it's time to output the results to disk.
Mainly you have two ways of doing this. One is to use Movie Render Queue or MRQ for short, and this method delivers the best outputs. We'll cover it in the next section.
The other method is to use a legacy output, and as the name implies, it is older technology with less quality and fewer features, but its simplicity can be used for fast previews.
For still renderings or essentially screenshots, you can go to a frame you like,
and then use the Viewport menu to access the High Resolution Screenshot option.
Here you can define a Screenshot Multiplied value, but be careful not to go overboard. If your current screen is set to HD, a 2x multiplier will give you a 4K resolution.
In general, try to restrict yourself to a maximum of 3x for a preview.
You have some additional features to choose from, but for now, click the Capture button to save this frame to disk.
The image is saved to the Project Saved folder, and you can open it in File Manager.
You can view its properties, and note that in my case, the resolution is set to 2432x1368. That's double the resolution seen in my current viewport.
Note that the Multiplier works on the viewport resolution, and not on your Windows desktop resolution.
View the image.
You'll see that it has some anti-aliasing issues that you can greatly improve later in MRQ, but for a preview, it's acceptable.
You'll also notice that any non-renderable icons in the viewer are also saved as part of the image. After all, it's just a screen capture.
So you may want to hide these with the G key prior to exporting the image.
To render animation previews, you can use the Movie Screen Capture, and the G key to export the image.
You can also use the G key to export the image.
To render animation previews, you can use the Movie Screen Capture, Legacy option, from the Sequencer toolbar, and then click the Render button.
A dialog opens giving you various output options including AVI files.
You can change the frame rate,
or the resolution,
or the resolution.
You can also change compression quality, although you cannot change the codec. A higher compression quality results in a bigger AVI file.
There are some additional options to choose from but none that affect the quality of the output.
As you click the Capture Movie button, you can save your scene and wait for the AVI output to compile.
You will see it render in a preview window.
Once it's done, it will be saved to the Project Save folder under a dedicated Video Captures subfolder.
From there, you can double-click it to play it back with your assigned movie player.
This would work fine as a quick preview to share with clients and colleagues but when it comes to creating high-quality outputs, you had better rely on Mover in the queue, which we'll learn about in the next section.
Thank you for watching!